Corea del Norte es tal vez el país más hermético,
cerrado y aislado del planeta. Un país que
en 2018 parece vivir en 1960.
Sin embargo… amigos, ahora toda esta historia
puede estar a punto de cambiar.
Aquí en VisualPolitik, ya os contamos en
un pasado vídeo como el capitalismo está
llegando a Corea del Norte de la mano de los
mercados populares, como se está produciendo
toda una revolución emprendedora y cómo
hoy más del 50% de los norcoreanos viven
gracias a la economía privada.
Sin embargo nos quedaron sobre la mesa un
par de preguntas…
¿Qué piensa uno de los gobiernos más totalitarios
del planeta sobre esta particular revolución
capitalista?¿Qué planes tiene? y otra cuestión
muy, pero que muy importante ¿Quién diantres
estaría dispuesto a invertir en Corea del
Norte? Atentos.
NO SON LOS MEJORES MOMENTOS
El 12 de junio de 2018 se celebró en Singapur
un encuentro histórico…
Por primera vez, el Presidente de los Estados
Unidos, en este caso Donald Trump, se reunía
con un líder norcoreano.
¿El objetivo? Supuestamente
desnuclearizar Corea del Norte.
¿El objetivo probablemente real?
Bueno, además de hacerse un par de fotos
- qué oye nunca viene mal -, recobrar el
diálogo, enfriar la enorme tensión que se
había generado e, impedir que Corea del Norte
continuará con un programa nuclear que le
podría haber llevado a tener capacidad de
ataque sobre los mismísimos Estados Unidos.
Claro que… esperad un momento porque una
cosa es la teoría y otra la realidad, que
puede ser un poco diferente. Atentos a las
últimas novedades:
(“Las agencias de espionaje de Estados Unidos:
Corea del Norte está trabajando en nuevos
misiles” Washington Post.)
(“El secretario de estado Mike Pompeo reconoció
durante un testimonio en el Senado que las
fábricas norcoreanas “continúan produciendo
material fisible” usado en la producción
de armas nucleares”)
Y es que a día de hoy, tal y como ya os contamos
aquí en VisualPolitik, parece un poquito
difícil que el régimen Pyongyang acepte
- al menos a corto plazo - desprenderse de
todas sus armas nucleares, que al fin y al
cabo son su mejor seguro de vida.
Pero… claro, eso no quiere decir que no
acepte hacer concesiones para normalizar sus
relaciones con el resto del mundo y terminar
con las sanciones internacionales.
Porque, vereis.… desde que Kim Jong Un llegó
al poder en 2011 ha tenido dos prioridades,
por un lado el desarrollo de la bomba nuclear…
pero por otro… algo bastante menos tenebroso…
la reforma económica.
(Sí, aunque parezca difícil de creer, teniendo
en cuenta tanto sus discursos como sus acciones,
los cambios que está impulsado… el dictador
norcoreano quiere cambiar la mala situación
económica del país copiando algunos de los
cambios que han protagonizado antes países
como China o Vietnam.)
Y, ojo, porque una vez desarrolladas las capacidades
nucleares… la prioridad número 1 de Pyongyang
es avanzar en el desarrollo económico…
….y para lograrlo necesitan terminar con
las sanciones internacionales… que están
causando un daño enorme. [Sí, vamos a ver,
aunque parezca difícil la situación en Corea
del Norte aún puede empeorar]
Fijaos, por ejemplo, en lo que ha ocurrido
con las relaciones comerciales entre Corea
del Norte y Latinoamérica… entre las sanciones
y el hundimiento de Venezuela [Uno de los
pocos países aliados de Corea del Norte en
todo el mundo] las relaciones se han hundido:
Pero… claro… cuando hablamos de Corea
del Norte y de economía, hablamos necesariamente
de China: el 80% de todo el comercio norcoreano
y de toda la entrada de divisas se produce
a través del gigante asiático.
Y lo que ha ocurrido es que China lleva años
presionando a Pyongyang para que de una vez
por todas ponga en marcha las reformas.
Y cómo esos cambios han ido más lentos que
una tortuga con reuma pues… el año pasado
Pekín decidió empezar a aplicar las sanciones
internacionales…Esto es lo que ocurría
en el mes de agosto de 2017:
(“China impone las primeras sanciones a
Corea del Norte en plena crisis con EEUU”.)
Tall y como os podéis imaginar, teniendo
en cuenta la enorme dependencia que Corea
del Norte tiene de China esto supone un desastre.
(Tan solo en los 6 primeros meses de 2018
las compras chinas de productos norcoreanos
se han desplomado más de un 90%... y las
exportaciones chinas hacia Corea del Norte
un 40%. Todo esto, claro, en el mercado oficial…
luego, tal y como vimos aquí, está el mercado
paralelo, el mercado negro, pero eso es otra
historia.
El caso es que todo esto ha causado que la
producción industrial y minera norcoreana
estén viviendo su peor momento en años.)
Y si a todo esto le sumamos el desastroso
estado de las infraestructuras… con apagones
continuos de electricidad, menos de 1.000
km de carreteras pavimentadas en todo el país
y trenes decrépitos que funcionan en muchas
casos a poco más de 20km por hora… está
claro que el país necesita urgentemente un
cambio de 180 grados…
Y ¿sabéis qué? En Pyongyang lo saben.
¿PUEDE COREA DEL NORTE CONVERTIRSE EN EL
NUEVO VIETNAM?
En 1986 Vietnam puso en marcha la conocida
como política del Doi Moi, un conjunto de
reformas económicas similares a las de Deng
Xiaoping en China que tenían la misión de
dejar a un lado el comunismo y poner en marcha
una economía de mercado.
(Para ello se disolvieron las cooperativas
agrícolas, se eliminaron los controles de
precios, se permitió la propiedad de la tierra,
y se pusieron en marcha políticas para atraer
la inversión extranjera.
Duran los siguientes 30 años, la economía
de Vietnam creció a una media anual de casi
el 7%. Hoy Vietnam está transformándose
a una velocidad vertiginosa y sus exportaciones
son ya más grandes que las de países como
Brasil o Australia.)
Pues precisamente… en la pasada cumbre intercoreana
de abril entre Kim Jong Un y el presidente
de Corea del Sur, Moon Jae-in el líder norcoreano
manifestó su interés en seguir el modelo
de…. Vietnam.
Precisamente, en esta línea, el gobierno
norcoreano ha aprobado en los últimos años
algunas medidas significativos: ha impulsado
la creación de mercados privados, ha dado
más autonomía a las empresas públicas y
ha concedido parcelas de tierra para su explotación
privada a los campesinos.
Sin embargo… a pesar de todo esto, hay dos
preguntas que necesitamos contestar: ¿Quién
diantres estaría dispuesto a invertir en
Corea del Norte? y ¿Qué más está dispuesto
a hacer el gobierno de Pyongyang? Atentos.
¿QUIÉN INVERTIRÍA EN COREA DEL NORTE?
Si nos preguntaran en qué países nos gustaría
hacer negocios, probablemente Corea del Norte
sería una de nuestras últimas opciones…
[¿Invertir en un país tan totalitario, donde
el líder hace y deshace a su antojo, donde
el gobierno actúa con una enorme brutalidad
y se dedica a amenazar al resto del planeta?¿Invertir
en un país donde el Estado de Derecho y la
seguridad jurídica son pura fantasía? ¡Venga
ya!]
Pues… amigos, lo cierto es que no todo el
mundo lo ve de esta forma.
(Algunas de las compañías más grandes de
Corea del Sur como Hyundai, Lotte Corporation
o Samsung ya han montado grupos de trabajo
para investigar y analizar oportunidades de
negocio potenciales en Corea del Norte y según
las encuestas las tres cuartas partes de las
empresas de Corea de Sur estarían dispuestas
a invertir en el norte si se levantan las
sanciones.
Hyundai, por ejemplo, se está preparando
ya para una pronta reapertura de la zona industrial
de Kaesong, una zona industrial junto a la
frontera con Corea del Sur que fue creada
en 2004 para albergar empresas extranjeras
-mayoritariamente surcoreanas- y que llegó
a dar trabajo a más de 80.000 norcoreanos…
Pero que en 2013 ante las crecientes tensiones
entre las dos Coreas fue cerrado por el gobierno
de Pyongyang.)
Incluso, recientemente Jim Rogers, uno de
los inversores más importantes y conocidos
de todos los tiempos se ha lamentado de que
los Estados Unidos no le permiten invertir
en Corea del Norte y ha hecho declaraciones
como estas:
("Corea va a ser ahora el país más excitante
del mundo. Kim Jong-un no quiere una guerra.
Kim no es norcoreano. Fue educado en suiza.
Sabe que hay un mundo diferente fuera de allí.
Necesitan de todo: electricidad, jabón, manteles…
Si tienes cualquier tipo de pericia, vas a
hacer una fortuna”. Jim Rogers)
Claro que… un momento… la pregunta que
nos podemos hacer, es ¿Qué diantres ven
en un país como Corea del Norte?
Pues... fundamentalmente oportunidades.
Vereis, me explico, Corea del Norte tiene
una población relativamente joven, muy emprendedora
y con bajísimos costes laborales.
Además, eso no es todo, según parece el
país podría ser muy rico en recursos naturales:
oro, zinc, cobre, tierras raras… el valor
estimado de todos los recursos minerales es
de más de 6 billones de dólares.
Luego tal y como dice Jim Rogers el país
está por hacer, necesita de todo. Y por si
eso fuera poco, además se encuentra en medio
de dos potencias económicas, China y Corea
del Sur.
Fijaos, en la pasado cumbre intercoreana,
el Presidente de Corea del Sur le entregó
a Kim Jong-Un un pendrive donde se incluían
un montón de inversiones que Corea del Sur
estaría dispuesta a realizar.
(Por ejemplo, Seúl estaría muy interesado
en construir ferrocarriles trans-coreanos
que además de impulsar la economía norcoreana
le permitirían a Corea del Sur exportar mercancías
de forma mucho más rápida a China. Y lo
mismo con carreteras, oleoductos, etcétera,
etcétera… los planes serían milmillonarios.)
Claro que…un momento, porque no todo es
tan sencillo y el entusiasmo no es ni mucho
menos generalizado. Corea del Norte es una
brutal dictadura, la corrupción es enorme
y el gobierno puede hacer, literalmente lo
que le dé la gana, por ejemplo, expropiarte:
(“Aquí es donde se va a hacer el dinero,
si usted puede averiguar cómo no ser expropiado".
Justin Hastings, profesor asociado de la Universidad
de Sydney)
Claro que... en algunos casos un elevado riesgo puede ser compensado con altas rentabilidades...
Pero luego, por supuesto, está el tema de las
sanciones internacionales… como consecuencia
del programa nuclear. Y, hasta que no se levanten…
cualquier cambio tendrá un recorrido muy
corto.
Ahora bien, es precisamente en este punto
donde China puede jugar un papel muy relevante.
Vereis, Xi Jinping ha conseguido lo que lleva
años buscando: que Pyongyang se ponga las
pilas. [Lo que evidentemente podría ser un
gran negocio para las empresas chinas]
Y por eso ahora, fijaos.
(“China ya pide que se levanten sanciones
contra Corea del Norte tras la cumbre en Singapur”)
Y no solo eso, China está permitiendo el
mercado negro entre los dos países, ha acelerado
los planes de desarrollo en la zona fronteriza
y ya están estudiando la inminente apertura
de zonas económicas especiales en la frontera
con Corea del Norte…
Y luego está el turismo… que precisamente
es una de las grandes prioridades del gobierno
de Kim Jong Un. Atentos.
(COREA DEL NORTE, ¿LUGAR DE VACACIONES?)
La llegada de turistas chinos no ha parado
de crecer en los últimos años y desde Mayo
de 2019 el número de llegadas diarias se
ha más que duplicado.
(“Vamos a operar al menos siete u ocho rutas
turísticas a Corea del Norte este año, incluyendo
un viaje de un día a Nanyo y un viaje de
cuatro a cinco días a Pyongyang, Kaesong
y Panmunjom”- Che Jing, subdirector de una
agencia de viajes china)
Pues...precisamente, el turismo es una de
las prioridades del gobierno de Pyongyang…
por varios motivos:
primero para generar empleo - recordad es
un sector muy intensivo en mano de obra -atraer
inversiones y conseguir rápidamente divisas
extranjeras.
Por otro lado el turismo podría cambiar la
imagen del régimen… y, la verdad, cambiar
los desfiles nucleares y la amenaza nuclear
por playas exóticas y cenas con marismo…
sería algo bastante bueno para los negocios.
Por estos motivos, en 2014 el gobierno de
Corea del Norte creó la Zona Especial Turística
de Wonsan, una zona económica especial donde
se permite la inversión extranjera y donde
en principio, el régimen permitiría más
libertades para desarrollar el turismo.
[Sí, en la misma zona donde hasta hace poco
el ejército hacía ensayos como este]
(El caso es que con el programa nuclear y
las sanciones, los resultados han sido muy
pero que muy escasos… sin embargo Kim Jong
Un quiere pisar el acelerador.
Sin ir más lejos, en 2017 el gobierno de
Corea del Norte envió una delegación a España,
que como sabéis es una de las mayores potencias
turísticas del mundo, para conocer lugares
como Benidorm o Marina d´Or, aprender de
ellos y tomar ideas.)
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Según parece, el objetivo que manejan en
Pyongyang es conseguir atraer más de 1 millón
de turistas cada año en el corto plazo y
de 5 a 10 millones en futuro razonable.
La pregunta es, ¿Estará Kim Jong-Un realmente
dispuesto a llevar a cabo todas las reformas
que el país necesita para que todos estos
planes puedan hacerse realidad?
Amigos, solo el futuro podrá contestarnos
a esta pregunta.
De momento, lo que sí parece claro es que
estamos ante la mejor oportunidad para dejar
atrás la pesadilla norcoreana, que no solo
es una amenaza para el resto del mundo sino
sobre todo un castigo de miedo y represión,
una gran cárcel para los propios norcoreanos.
Pero ahora… turno para ti, ¿Eres partidario
de levantar las sanciones contra Corea del
Norte?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo no
olvides darle a like y si puedes echarnos
una mano en Patreon.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.